hello freak [ __ ] boom yes alive hello
Eric
hello Joe thanks for doing this man we
had a question you're you're not related
to that other fellow the other Weinstein
fella that's in trouble right now
Bret Weinstein no that's your brother
the other guy Oh Weinstein the other guy
yeah I don't know him okay that other
guys in trouble he's like two more women
Angelina Jolie and they both came out
today yeah I don't think it's gonna stop
there uh-uh seems like you might have
had a little bit of an issue
it's amazing that someone can get away
with something like that for so long and
then one or two people come clean and
the walls come down the oppressive fist
of just his [ __ ] tyranny whatever
that guy did yeah I mean I think it does
speak to the idea that power really
exists in an industry in a town like
this well it's always been the that's
been the cliche right the casting couch
right yes but I didn't know in the
modern era how much how much power
anyone still had yeah I wonder you know
it's just and it's also like super
left-wing guy you know like really
politically connected to social justice
ideologies fighting gun control I mean
you know promoting gun control and
stumping for Hillary and all this yeah
that seems like overcompensation
[Applause]
[Music]